ah
[Música]
i
la unión europea es el mayor donante
mundial de ayuda humanitaria a alemania
francia y suecia son los países que más
aportan actualmente la unión europea
tiene presupuestados 11.000 millones de
euros para los próximos 7 años esto es
un 15% más que los presupuestos
anteriores pero si se tiene en cuenta
todas las partidas de ayuda humanitaria
también para catástrofes naturales está
ayuda asciende a los 50 mil millones de
euros anuales de hechos en los
presupuestos europeos nos llegarán a
aprobar la ayuda humanitaria se seguiría
fluyendo para que muchos países sigan
obteniendo esta ayuda la unión europea
sobre todo ha ofrecido en los últimos
años especial ayuda a áfrica central
pero también a la región de oriente
medio y también a américa central
especialmente por la crisis de
refugiados derivada por la crisis
política en venezuela y también por la
intensa campaña que ha habido de
huracanes en toda la región
[Música]
uno de los objetivos del presidente
electo joe biden es recuperar el papel
de liderazgo de eeuu en el mundo''
comprometiendo a otros países en causas
como el cambio climático la no
proliferación nuclear y la ayuda de los
refugiados en este sentido se espera que
en los próximos cuatro años haya una
ayuda humanitaria más significativa por
parte de eeuu en el mundo'' reactivando
y recuperando su presencia e influencia
en el mundo es una posición afín a las
políticas humanitarias desarrolladas ya
en el pasado por el nombrado secretario
de estado- anthony blinken y distintas a
las de trump quien durante sus últimos
cuatro años recortó la ayuda
internacional a muchos países que fueron
aliados de eeuu
[Música]
el gobierno británico redujo en cerca de
4 billones de libras esterlinas el apoyo
internacional las ayudas internacionales
en el presupuesto de 2021 el ministro de
finanzas explicó que esta decisión tuvo
que adaptarse para rescatar la colapsada
economía por cuenta de la pandemia del
coronavirus esta medida veía venirse con
la eliminación del cargo de la persona
encargada de estos asuntos dentro del
gabinete por supuesto la medida ha
despertado muchas críticas para el
primer ministro dentro de su partido el
conservador y de organizaciones de
caridad quienes consideran que se está
perdiendo la reputación del reino unido-
ahora que la solidaridad internacional
es más que necesaria por la pandemia y
además en la época post break sheet esta
medida muestra una vez más que las
baterías y las prioridades del primer
ministro están en casa y no
necesariamente a nivel internacional
[Música]